an important cultural moment when a
police chief took the stand
to testify against one of his former
officers madara arredondo
said the alleged crime george floyd
committed passing a fake 20 dollar bill
did not merit the initial response of
guns drawn
and the force used to restrain him was
unnecessary
once there was no longer any resistance
and clearly when mr floyd was no longer
responsive and even motionless
to continue to apply
that level of force
to a person proned out
handcuffed behind their back um
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that uh
is by policy is not part of our training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values
the police chief also told the jury the
officers on the scene that day in may
last year
had an obligation and the training to
provide
basic medical treatment to their
prisoner we have a duty of care
and so when someone is in our custody
um regardless if they're a suspect uh
we have a obligation to make sure that
we provide for their care
this was a significant moment critics
have often complained about the
so-called blue wall
police officers refusing to give
evidence against one another
this was a mighty big crack in the wall
chief aaron dondo
the man who fired derek shoving the day
after george floyd died
an important witness for the prosecution
earlier the court heard from the doctor
who pronounced george floyd dead
dr bradford lagenfeld tried for 30
minutes to revive him
to save his life he said he believed
what happened at the scene
could have been responsible was your
leading theory then
for the cause of mr floyd's cardiac
arrest
oxygen oxygen deficiency that was
one of the more likely possibilities i
felt that at the time
based on the information i had it was
more likely than the other possibilities
and and doctor is there another name for
death by oxygen deficiency asphyxia
is a commonly understood term
under cross-examination the doctor
agreed that the use of drugs might also
cause significant problems
leading to asphyxia it's expected day
seven
will spend a lot of time considering
expert medical testimony
a part that may be key to the
prosecution case
alan fisher al-jazeera at the chauvin
trial in minneapolis
now debbie hines is a legal analyst and
former prosecutor from the city of
baltimore
she says the police chief's testimony is
a key moment in the trial so far
so it's very interesting to have the
police chief to testify because
what was heard earlier it's very rare
that a police chief will testify
against officers in his own department
and what he did was he actually
bolstered what lieutenant zimmerman had
testified to
earlier um not one today and that was
the unreasonable use of force on mr
floyd
but i think that what the chief did is
he painted the picture of
what the police force should be about
and that's what this case is about
what should be done not what often
happens and so he stated that the police
officers they have a duty of care to the
suspect that they address
and that duty is to render aid where aid
is necessary
so it was also a broken there where
shoving didn't even
give the least the least bit of concern
and one of the things i think the
officer also did is that the chief did
excuse me as he talked about the
sanctity of life
and that's very important because that's
what is in contrast to what we're seeing
that derek shoving showed
no regard for human life with respect to
derek joven
but most importantly we're seeing the
officer
uh the chief excuse me i keep calling an
officer he is the chief of police for
the minneapolis uh police department
to say that there was clearly
unreasonable use of force there's no
other way to mince using the words that
mr floyd
was not resisting arrest in any way
shape or form
and that he should not have been pinned
down for the length of time
that he was pinned down